eu leaders are meeting in brussels today
top of the agenda soaring energy prices
the eu will address its toolbox of
measures to tackle the energy crunch
including direct income support for
vulnerable households subsidies for
struggling companies and tax reductions
in the final bill
so let's take a look at those prices in
germany heating oil prices left by
almost 77 in september compared to last
year and prices for natural gas in
europe have skyrocketed over 420
in the last year 420
russia of course is the main eu supplier
of natural gas and critics have long
been warning that the eu could be too
dependent on russian gas which also led
to the controversy surrounding the north
stream two pipeline which has yet to go
online now russian president vladimir
putin defended the pipeline saying its
approval would ease europe's energy
problems
the german regulator must make an
appropriate decision
but they have not yet made this decision
of course
if we were able to increase supplies
along this route
we can say with absolute certainty that
the tension in the european energy
market would significantly decrease
this would of course also affect the
prices on the european gas market
so that was vladimir putin's take on
europe's energy crunch
let's listen now to the opinion of
mikhail crookty crook t
he is a co-founder and the leading
analyst of rus energy an independent
consultant agency based in moscow so
very good to have you on the program
so mikhail in your opinion what is
causing the current gas shortages and
rising prices in europe
good morning
first it started with some
well market reasons because the demand
was very high in asia and lng carriers
and traders rushed into asia and europe
felt that there was some sort of a
shortage of gas and the prices went up
in europe after they had increased in
asia then gas prom
went uh on offensive
and when i say gas problem i mean the
russian government because the company
is managed by the russian government and
by the the rest president directly
gazprom announced it was not going to uh
increase
gas deliveries to europe uh apart from
the long-term contracts it had already
signed
then gazprom announced it was not
increasing
well storage of gas in its underground
storage facilities in germany and other
countries of europe and then yes
yes and then gas problem announced it
was not increasing uh it was no it was
not going to sell additional additional
gas
on spot contracts during the fourth
quarter and uh the whole next year
all of that of course uh mikhail mikhail
if i just can comment because all of
that what you're just telling us
obviously is not very helpful and it's
quite the opposite of what vladimir
putin keeps saying
in a recent interview that you gave to a
german media outlet you said that he is
basically declaring war on the eu using
russia's gas reserves as his main weapon
why do you think he would do this
yes because uh well basically we see it
is not for commercial reasons that the
russian government is decreasing gas
supply to europe it is purely uh
political reasons in fact what
president putin said it was blackmail
if you want more gas you must uh well
sanction
the uh
commissioning of north stream to
pipeline unless you do that you will not
have gas
we know that there is plenty of capacity
in the ukrainian pipelines in the
ukrainian route and russia could very
easily supply additional gas to
germany and other countries but
the announcement if you want guess
please uh do something about uh north
stream too this is blackmail this is war
in fact right right uh mikhail just very
briefly because not stream two is not
yet active is not yet online and many
people say it should never go online
very brief your opinion should the eu
should germany now cancel nordstrom 2
it is a redundant pipeline because
europe can do without very easily the
capacity of the ukrainian route the
polish route and the uh first uh no
stream route is quite enough to satisfy
double the capacity of demand in europe
so it is redundant i don't think there
is any need to open germany and europe
to a new black male from russia
all right mikhail crutiken
from rus energy in moscow thank you so
much for your time and for your input